a salvo unas 164 personas fueron
evacuadas en helicóptero del área de
seibert plate con lo cual el número de
personas que dejaron sus hogares
asciende a 400 pudieron del incendio
bautizado como clic que desde el viernes
ha consumido el bosque nacional cierra
en el centro de california destruyendo
unas 60.000 hectáreas y afectando al
menos 65 edificaciones y lo peor la
temporada de mayor número de incendios
ni siquiera ha comenzado pero ya ha
establecido un récord de más de 900 mil
hectáreas quemadas este año en medio de
condiciones climáticas extremas
los vientos básicamente empujan ese
fuego en todas las direcciones y eso es
algo con lo que hemos tenido que lidiar
durante los últimos días además la ola
de calor que tuvimos el fin de semana y
que la seguimos teniendo en graham para
el gobernador del estado la creciente
intensidad de los incendios forestales
es consecuencia del cambio climático de
un sprint sin proceder conforme estamos
experimentando una confluencia de
problemas sin precedentes este año que
no sufrimos el año pasado temperaturas
récord sin precedentes un calor que
impactó toda la costa oeste
eeuu hay que incluir gente concluyó que
el cambio climático ha impactado en la
realidad que estamos experimentando
experience y por el momento se desconoce
la causa del incendio clic pero se ha
confirmado otro incendio en el sur del
estado
al parecer una fiesta de revelación de
género sería la responsable del incendio
del dorado cerca de yucaipa en el
condado de san bernardino
la pareja que espera un bebé utilizó un
dispositivo pirotécnico que emitía humo
rosa o azul para anunciar el sexo de su
hijo unos 14.000 bomberos están en
primera línea combatiendo 25 incendios
en todo el estado